meine Damen und Herren herzlich
willkommen wieder zu wer weiß mehr dem
großen Quiz auf YouTube
heute unser Gast Bülent Ceylan herzlich
willkommen
so du weißt was und was es heute geht
und welches Fach Thema
Bülent Ceylan wir hatten gedacht du
könntest vielleicht sogar Experte sein
was dieses Thema angeht pass auf
wie viel
Google-Treffer gibt es wenn man nach dir
googelt sind es 1 rund 1,3 Millionen wer
die Lösung a sind es
2,4 Millionen sind es C
3,3 Millionen oder sind es
d6,7 Millionen wie viel Google Treffer
gibt es wenn man nach dir sucht ich
glaube
2,4
bist du sicher
nicht aber ich glaube willst du
einloggen
2,4 Millionen
das ist leider falsch ehrlich es sind
3,3 Millionen du kannst stolz sein aber
leider kein Punkt schade so mist das tut
mir leid aber lieber so
übrigens die 1,3 Millionen wären ein
Kaya Yanar gewesen ah okay wie viel
Einwohner mit Migrationshintergrund
ich frage mich immer was das ist ist das
so eine Tafel oder jemand hinter sich
genau genau wie viel Einwohner hat mit
Migrationshintergrund hat Mannheim in
Prozent
sind es 20%
, also rund sind es eher rund 20% rund
30 %. rund 40 % oder D rund 50 %
von Mannheim genau
natürlich eine ich glaube
man denkt immer so sind so Sophie und so
aber ich glaube es sind
ich glaube es sind
30%
. möchtest du das Einloggen
wirklich 30 %
B 30% lockst du ein okay er loggt 30
sind das denke ich dann denke ich dachte
erst
linger ist wenig aber es ist dann in
letzten Endes auch nicht wenig aber ich
sagte
b13%. und wieder zeigt sich er hat keine
Ahnung
es sind rund 40 %. 40
gedacht
gut okay pass auf und eine letzte Frage
pass auf die nächste Frage das machen
wir immer großes was ist die Leute doch
so wenig Ahnung über sich haben
gemeine Frage pass auf also ich meine
jetzt hier in Frankfurt im Stadion auf
wie heißt das Stadion vom Eintracht
Frankfurt
welchen Zuschauerschnitt hatte Eintracht
Frankfurt in der letzten Saison
26.400 also rund
26.400
37.640.000
300 42.000
ja okay wieder eingeloggt wieder falsch
nein es sind 37.6
ich dachte weil die erst jetzt sind wie
ein erste Liga
nee die hätten nicht so viel aber das
ist ja die Fans sind immer treu ja das
tut mir natürlich sehr leid aber sorry
ich bin auch nicht so der Fußball
alles liebe Leute habe ich bei dem
bemerkt ja
wer liebe Leute ja das Publikum ach so
ja ja alles liebe Leute
ja natürlich absolut also Backen z.B das
ist friedlichste Festival äh eine eines
der friedlichen Festival der Welt also
das Rock am Ring viel brutaler gut okay
ein Argument für Hilfe